all right I want to bring on these I've
been excited for these guests for over a
month now but out of deference to
selling books I decided to wait until
their book was coming out the book is
persecuted from within how the Saints
endured crises in the church written by
Joshua Charles and Alec Torres who are
those gentlemen oh I just sort of
introduced them already Joshua is a
Catholic convert from protestantism
former White House speech writer number
one New York Times best-selling author
historian classical pianist what does
doesn't this guy do and Alec Torres also
is a former speech writer for president
Trump and speaker McCarthy and has
ghostwritten for cabinet secretaries
ambassadors National media personalities
perhaps I should have him ghost write
this show so that I can spend more time
sitting out at night with my children
and smoking cigars gentlemen thank you
for coming on the show it's an Michael
appreciate it so guys I want to
begin first with you Josh because I see
Alec and I we go way back to college
but you and I go back to my Twitter feed
just a few months ago where you started
amid all the stupid trash that I get in
my Twitter feed memes and porn robots
and I just people bickering with each
other and Hawking their books and
everything you you just post really
thoughtful writing on the church fathers
it seems to me that you have read every
single document that has ever been
produced in Christendom from the
thorough of these
writings well I'm trying to Michael well
first of all thank you I know I speak
for Alec as well we we both appreciate
your classy substantive and uh and very
humorous witness to the truth of our
faith so thank you very much but yeah I
the fathers converted me uh they're I
people probably can't see him but
they're on either side here um and uh
yeah there's a lot there's a lot of lack
of substance on Twitter and um you know
the truth of our faith is uh it's a
matter of life and death for all
eternity and so just try to share the
truth of that and so thank you very much
i' I've had a have a sister of mine who
just came into the church and she is a
huge fan of yours and she was like
Michael nolles is following I didn't
even realize you were following me for
quite a bit and uh and then I kept
noticing my some of my tweets got quite
a few shares and Views and and then I
found out why apparently so so thank you
she's she's a huge fan well I really
appreciate that it's great news I love
also that you know you kind of like me
uh not always practicing the faith you
know I I was a revert so I was a cradle
Catholic and then I went away for 10
years and was brought back in through a
calvinist philosopher at a Catholic
University and a whole bunch of like
crazy stuff that ended up bringing me
back to the church but when when you say
you're a convert from
protestantism like how Protestant were
you you know sometimes people will say
this is my favorite thing that liberal
atheists say they say listen I went to
Catholic Church for like one SE semester
I I one time took a class at the local
Catholic Rec Center so I'm basically
Thomas aquinus and I know everything
about so how how Protestant were you
before you converted yeah no I mean as a
Protestant I wouldn't claim I was raised
in an anti-catholic household but you
know it was kind of in the air like that
was the church we left and good riddance
and you know I I I Thought I Loved
Martin Luther and you know there was a
2003 movie Luther with Joseph fiend in
it Ralph fiend's brother I believe and I
loved it and it good movie I like
that well besides it being utter and
complete propaganda yeah and so um so
but I loved it and and Luther Rah raw so
but I you know we would occasionally go
to mass with my Mexican aunt and um you
know so I wasn't super anti Catholic but
you know I I just love the Bible and I
kept reading the Bible and you know
frankly over many years things just
weren't adding up I kept thinking some
smarter guy had figured it out and I
just kept not finding the smarter guy
and then I read the fathers and it all
clicked together and I realized the
Catholic faith had been the Christian
faith from the very beginning and that's
the extremely short version Alec you're
up you were you were always a uh a
Catholic were you not or were you also
actually I just hung out with a bunch of
Catholics at school but that's probably
why I became Catholic in the end I
actually I'm a convert from
protestantism as well so I wouldn't want
to take away Josh's witness here but uh
take it away take it away how Protestant
were you I I was pretty darn Protestant
actually you know like like you know the
the uh the like a strange Boy Scout
group of of evangelicals the aanas that
that's what I was like as a kid you know
me memorizing Bible verses and getting
badges for it and things like that so I
was I was pretty darn Protestant back
then so then what got you was it was it
the same story was it the the church
fathers or was it something
else it was different than Josh's uh uh
you know because the Lord comes at
people from completely different
directions sometimes so for Josh it
really was the church fathers he he read
his way into it he was faced with it
intellectually and had this big
transformation for me part of it was I
just thought Catholics were weird I
didn't think yeah that might be fair
yeah and I now that I am one I mean we
are weird let's be honest with ourselves
but I was like I don't know if I want to
be a part with these people so uh so I
met a bunch of good Catholics at Yale of
all places right you go to like the
worst places in the world and it happens
to be where Grace abounds as well and
I'm like wait these people are actually
extremely intelligent why do they seem
to know answers to all the questions or
if they don't they come back to me the
next day and they have like documents to
back them up right right I I found the
same thing you know I found a lot of I
maybe not most but a lot of people at
Yale were very smart a lot of them were
much smarter than me and a lot of them
were atheist a lot of them were super
lib and but I did find the smartest
people the very smartest people and most
serious people on campus were religious
and they tended to be Christian broadly
and even the even at the time you know
maybe it was split 50/50 Catholic
Protestant a lot of them since then have
become Catholic uh and a little bit
Eastern Orthodox a lot a lot of people
write in on on the question of
Catholicism they'll say you know I'm I'm
uh going back to the church or I'm
converting or whatever and uh but
they'll sometimes say you know I'm
converting at this period of intense
confusion and actually crisis in the
church and some people look at that and
they say this is the worst possible time
to convert to Catholicism other people
might say though no actually it's the
best time uh because we've seen these
these sorts of crises before and somehow
miraculously the church always seems to
survive which I guess is the topic of
your book yeah that's 100% the case I
want you both to speak at exactly the
same time if possible and same thing
show that're like the best co-authors in
the world uh I I kind of find ironic
sometimes I tell people hey it's
wonderful I worked with this guy we
wrote a book it's about all these
terrible things that happened to
extremely good and holy people by the
very people who should have loved them
and respected them the most you know
they were imprisoned and sometimes
martyred excommunicated bad things
happened but don't worry it's a really
hopeful book and then like Ian like what
are you talking about the the hopeful
part is that we look back and we're like
wait bad things have happened before
confusing times have happened before and
God always sees us through God always
brings his Saints out through the end
and he raises up incredible holy people
in every single age to fight the good
fight and to lead people towards the
truth so you know we can look at our own
time now and we can say oh woe is I or
you could say well Lord you put me in
one hell of a fight you know prepare me
because I'm ready for it what do you
think about the timing you know the book
is released just as we are on the brink
of World War III a a World War
potentially that is focused around the
holy land and around theological
Conflict at a time when there are barely
any Christians left even in the Holy
Land
Josh um I I joked with my White House
colleagues back in the day we were all
converts uh mostly from protestantism
and I said you know the thing that sucks
about being Catholic is we can't
complain about suffering anymore and of
course that's the most glorious aspect
of our faith because it's what our Lord
did and I was talking with a friend the
other day Jason Jones a Human Rights Act
activists filmmaker Catholic guy uh
Michael you would love him by the way he
his his line with Protestants is I don't
worship Mary I worship statues of Mary
he's joking course but it's one of my
one of my all-time favorite lines just
to mess with people and anyway it's it's
learned a lot of car but no uh we were
talking I said to him you know I think
I've been pondering this issue of
suffering and how can you not as a
Catholic and I I said you know if
somebody said came to you and said I
have the secret for you to never engage
in evil ever do you want to know what it
is yeah and the answer of our faith
would be suffer like Christ and keep
doing that till you die and you'll get
Eternal reward that's all you have to do
it's like but who wants that answer you
know nobody in a natural sense wants
that answer um but uh I I actually came
into the church July 2019 so my first
Easter was
2020 and one of the things I studied in
the fathers was the unanimous consensus
of the fathers which session four of can
the Council of Trent says is binding on
Catholics as a convert of course I know
that um but it says that one of the
things Antichrist will do is bring the
public celebration of the mass to an end
for three and a half years so I didn't
know in March 2020 whether maybe we were
starting that but I didn't anyway but
but you get the point it was a type of
what Antichrist would do and so it was a
very dramatic dare I say eschatological
apocalyptic time to come into the church
um I do personally think it's arguably
the worst time and I had a lot of
Catholic friends warn me beforehand I
have some very funny stories that
unfortunately I can't tell because some
of the people who said them are very
prominent public Catholics that I have
to wait till they die but but they made
jokes about it too you know making jokes
about as the pope Catholic frankly and
uh and I I love the Holy Father pray for
him every day um and and I'll leave it
to God but the the stories of these
Saints is basically um The Suffering of
Christ is not just suffering from
external enemies but from etal enemies
uh the Judas aspect of the church this
is this is baked into the very
constitution of the church um and you
know it's connected to a million
different things like one of the ways we
differ with Protestants uh most
Protestants not all but uh we don't
believe in divorce and this is
intimately connected with Ephesians 5
and Paul's saying marriage is a type of
of Christ in the church and so when
Christ married himself through the blood
of the Cross to his church there's no
divorce uh and so you have to bear the
internal Judas element with him um that
includes I mean with all these uh with
all these different uh Saints in here
from bishops from religious from priests
from Layman sometimes even from popes uh
I mean one one of the ones I worked on
St Jon of Arc she was killed you know
she she appealed to the pope can andlaw
secure this right for her uh but the
local ordinary said nope and she ended
up being killed and so the the the price
faced by many of these Saints was very
high but you know they are eternally
before God in heaven interceding for us
now uh because they they accepted this
element of suffering not just from
external enemies but internal enemies as
well and I don't think anybody's going
to see The Mystery of the faith see the
mystery of Christ see the mystery of of
the church unless they understand that
this mystery of suffering it's such a
great point you know I sometimes think
in my own life it's so bizarre that
right after I've been afforded some
incredible Grace some great uh ability
to accomplish something or you know uh
just a gift or some unexpected some
unexpected wonderful thing happens to me
it is at that point that I am most
tempted to sin and I think how that's so
unbelievably ungrateful of me why why
why is it that after I've received this
great news I want to go I don't know I
want to go hit the bar or I want to go
you know uh scream at somebody or I want
to mostly Ben Davies or I want to I
don't know just indulge some some kind
of uh Vice and the answer is I think Ed
to your point on suffering which is that
when we're when we're suffering we are
connecting ourselves to Christ on the
cross you know and we are uh aware of
the of of what the glories of this world
really mean um but when we get a little
looser and a little decadent and a
little comfortable and a little
luxurious then all of that goes out the
window and so suffering is not you know
it's not something that in a natural
sense we all are begging for but there
can be a a wonderfully sanctifying
aspect to it folks unfortunately I'm
completely out of time I want to have
you back and talk for another 7 or 20
hours uh perhaps we will do that on a
future the theology in the meantime
don't go by this sheet of paper go by
the actual book that has this cover from
the sheet of paper there it is there's
the real book persecuted from within
have the Saints endured crises in the
church Josh Charles Alec Torres thank
you both for coming on thank you Michael
thank you so much for having us great be
with great to be with all of you as well
I'm Michael N this is the Michael N show
see you
[Music]
tomorrow